are you feeling fit for purpose this
evening to be honest at the moment I'm
not sure I'm feeling fit for Boas at any
given point but I'll give it a go that's
fantastic so today we're talking about
human evolution and what happens when it
collides with the modern world the
imbalance between sort of who we are and
where we exists right yeah exactly
that's what the book is is fundamentally
about basically we're an evolved animal
and we're pretty we're pretty decent
right we're pretty cute evolved animal
we we fit very well to the world and
we've achieved global dominance as a
consequence but we have created now a
modern world environment that seems to
clash and we've got lots of problems in
the modern world that we can trap based
back to our evolutionary heritage to
greater or lesser extent sometimes it's
quite a playful thesis sometimes it
works quite nicely but we can see those
evolutionary echoes in the modern world
so that's that's the kind of overall
idea how much of an imbalance is there
between humans and the modern world
because sometimes I think that I'm doing
pretty all right
and then sometimes I feel a bit like an
alien yeah I think I think we have to
understand that we've changed the world
in such a massive and dramatic way in
some cases over the last decade I mean
if you think about it we're having a
conversation here over Skype I've got my
Twitter feed open we can talk about
things going viral and social media
stress and fofo and all that sort of
stuff that this would have been
meaningless even ten years ago and
that's just in one small aspect of our
life if we look across across the piste
I mean covert 19 is exposed of course
how globally connected we all are you
know we've got use the idea of getting
on flights and moving around the world
now is a very different place from what
it was a generation before and of course
if we look back over the last hundred
years or so it's it's a very different
place so we've we've always changed our
environment that's that's almost a
feature of humanity but the changes that
we produce now and the environment that
many of us now live in and what we call
the modern world is a very very
different world from well even a century
ago but actually the world in which we
we evolved you know if we look at a sort
of post agricultural revolution
ancestors ten thousand years ago and we
compare it to our lives now it's a
very very different sort of setup
although of course many aspects of it
are also the same so it's it is a
different world that we live in and I
think we have to accept them yeah I
suppose the first thing to realize here
is how slow evolution works and how
quick and effective we are at changing
our environment yeah that's right I mean
if you feel it back so the biggest
probably the biggest thing that happened
to us was that we worked out how to grow
food and obviously that's a pretty
decent thing to have worked out it saves
us a lot of time allows us to to expand
our technology and innovation because
we're no longer foraging for food and we
have a different sort of societal set up
but that came with problems so actually
when we developed agriculture there were
quite a lot of health problems dentition
we suffered from dental caries for for
the first time extensively for example
because of the the way that our skulls
were changing in our dentition were
changing so we did have evolutionary
change and that's slowly but surely
helped us to accommodate the changes
that were happening but we're talking
over thousands of years it wasn't as if
it wasn't like the internet revolution
where within five years everybody's
online you know that's not what how the
agricultural revolution worked it was
over a long period of time we also have
an evolutionary change in order to for
example digest milk so those of us that
have lactase persistence and are able to
drink raw milk that is an evolutionary
adaptation to to dairying into and to
farming so we see that happening quite
slowly and of course that's that's what
environmental changes are often like the
nonhuman induced but but recently we
we've seen environmental changes that
are just absolutely ridiculous I mean
you look across the world at the moment
at mega cities for example super cities
we have literally tens of millions of
people living on top of each other an
incredibly high density environments
that the number of people on the planet
is enormous compared to what it was the
technological shifts that have happened
you know these these are all
environmental changes now they're
changes to our our environment that
affect how we behave it affects how we
live and really the change over the last
let's call it the last generation you
know we can argue about whether it's 20
years or 30 years or 50 years actually
it doesn't really matter when we look at
it in the evolutionary terms because
it's too slow for us to you to evolve to
take account of it we have to have
social sort of accommodation for all
these environmental changes and it's
incredibly rapid and dramatic it really
is I was in Dubai a couple of years ago
with my dad and I couldn't believe just
how recent that city was yeah fishing
village I think wasn't it originally
insane
so obviously there's kind of two two
schools of thought
I suppose I brought the two skills that
I see one of them being the left-leaning
person who might look at the modern
world and look at inequities and
inequalities and stuff like that and
talk about it being bad but then someone
like Steven Pinker who would look
rationally to all of the ways with like
life expectancy and modern medicine and
things like that that are effective so
there's kind of this balancing board in
terms of how people see the world but I
guess evolution and humans and our
ability to adapt is that not going to
change at all no we're not going to sort
of evolve our way out of some of the
problems that we face right now I mean I
was thinking about this actually earlier
today because social media was was being
discussed on the radio so I was driving
and and you know I talked about social
media in the book but the way that we
have we have evolved an amazing capacity
for social behavior and that's almost a
definitional part of our species and the
ability for us to communicate in
language enhances that sociality and you
sort of get this runaway selection where
one enhances the other which increases
the benefits of the other our
intelligence you know receive this
across the animal kingdom or social
animals don't have larger brains you
know all of these things are intermixed
and interlinked but and we're incredibly
good at it right we're incredibly good
at living together cooperating working
together achieving incredible things
face to face and we know the rules and
most of us are able to you know read the
room and work out sort of emotional
engagements with people and we have an
emotional intelligence that lets us
navigate that environment but now we go
online and we sort of try to use those
same rules but it's a completely
different environment that we have to
operate in and people can say oh well
that's kind of a trivial example but but
but people commit suicide as it
consequences
interactions online that is the ultimate
lack of fitness right you to take your
own life as a consequence of something
you know that is really a very serious
thing it affects people's lives it
affects how people interact with it with
each other and their their mental health
and it's because we don't know the rules
now we've had thousands tens of
thousands of years of evolution to help
us build up the cognitive processes that
enable us to navigate our social world
in the real world we've had about ten
years to to work out the rules and of
course here and here's the thing right
as soon as we work out the rules the
social environment changes because
suddenly there's a new form so people I
think I saw I've got the impression
people were starting to get a handle on
how to use Facebook but then Twitter
came up on a sort of backpack broach and
suddenly everyone was getting quite
involved with that and that has a very
different vibe to it you know people say
things to me on Twitter they would never
say to my face you would never get up in
someone's face like that and say the
sorts of things that people will say on
there you know you just wouldn't do that
we've had tens of thousands of years of
social evolution that stop you from
doing that because you're likely to get
punched in her face but but but that
doesn't happen online so I think we
start to learn the rules and then
something new comes along we get
Instagram coming in when suddenly we get
this highly filtered version of
instagrams kind of an interesting one
isn't it it's quite a it has a high
potential for mental health damage I
think because of our tendency to sort of
compare and contrast with other people's
lives that that is something that we are
just coming to tears but as soon as we
do that of course well tick tocks around
now so that's the new big thing isn't it
and we'll get used to that and then of
the goalposts who move again so even
when we're able to get a handle on this
new environment we shift the environment
and it's just happening all the time and
I think that that is really the key
point we are we are changing what we do
and the way that we interact and the
environment that we're in in all kinds
of axes in ways that really are don't
just outstrip evolution I mean outstrip
evolution because they're happening sub
generationally but but they outstrip
even our ability to sit down and think
about it even our abilities just get a
basic handle on it and I think I think
we have to sit back sometimes and
realize just how remarkable we are and
that we can do these things and you know
you and I are having a calm
over the Internet this would have been a
ridiculous thing to consider a
generation ago but at the same time we
we aren't always up with the rules of
engagement and I think that's that's
something that we really need to to sort
out yeah there's an arms race going on
at the moment and there's a number of
different levels that its operating on
so technology and new modes of being
will always lead then probably a little
bit after that individuals might start
to adapt then some social norms might
arise around how groups should adapt
within that then lagging up behind that
the policy makers finally get their act
together and catch on to the fact that
we need GDP our online compliance or we
need to police what YouTube is policy is
able to do well what Twitter's policy is
able to do whatever it might be and then
bringing up the rear a couple of hundred
generations after that evolution is that
the old slow decrepid dog like at the
end of the leash like 50 yards behind
you just slowly creeping up behind and
we've got all of these and you totally
right like the arms race that's going on
between the pace that we're able to move
at as a society as a world and
everything else you know those layers
and layers they're several different
sort of filtering points at which we're
not able to keep up so I mean is
evolution right now is human evolution
kind of a little bit pointless because
by the time that you evolve the
environment that you've evolved to adapt
to will have changed yes and of course
many of the things we're talking about
you know evolution can only happen if
there's a genetic basis for the traits
that you're referring to you and if that
genetic basis affects surviving on
ultimately reproduction well that's your
fundamental aspects of it and and yeah
many of the features that plagued us in
in modern life might have some echoes in
evolution but they're not necessarily
affecting that they're not necessarily
affecting our reproduction if you like
so so our inability to handle social
media may well have
an evolutionary sort of echo in terms of
the types of social groups that we've
evolved to handle and the size of those
social groups and those sorts of
interactions right that that may well be
the mismatch that we see in the modern
world but our inability to handle that
doesn't necessarily affect our ability
to reproduce it doesn't become a
dominant feature it's not if you like
open to to natural selection in the
modern world so so evolution isn't going
to get us out of that problem even
though there may actually be some
genetic component to it right our
ability to handle larger groups could
well be a genetic component if we accept
that there is some evolutionary echo to
the way that we think about these things
then there's going to be some variation
of population and some people of course
can handle things better than others and
actually you know like I talked about in
the book it's first for some people
social media isn't a problem at all and
for other people it's a very big problem
and there's no reason to assume that
there may not be some underlying genetic
variants there it's going to be very
complex and it's going to be far from
straightforward but there could be
something there but is that ever going
to translate into a sort of meaningful
selection environment so that people
that have people that do well on Twitter
suddenly have more children only that's
they pass on that ability to do well on
Twitter you know that sort of
evolutionary scenario seems a little
unlikely but the biggest problem with it
is that is that but even even if that
were the case of course by the time
that's able to act in a generation or so
you know the problems the problems got
away because we've come up with a new
way of interacting I just I've just been
joined by by a almost two year-old who
should be dead hello darling you should
be downstairs so if I can if I can just
pause very quickly but I'm Salah
I'll have him removed tangled and
absolutely fine here we send the child
can choose oh that's it the child
catchers are coming all right
that's certainly fine two-year-old has
arrived yeah see you later on
just use your co-hosts for grief for a
brief while oh yeah well and illustrates
Oh could you close the door so no
[Music]
yes sorry about that so yeah and that
that's that's the big problem with with
all of these things is even if there was
enough variation enough of it was
genetic in the background then it made
some meaningful sense and people that
did well in certain things left more
offspring and than others by the time by
the time that happens the environments
changed we've changed the environment of
course you know there may be more subtle
effects with that I mean you know we
talked earlier about social media
causing problems one of those problems
is things like stress and you know we
can see some genetic basis and
differences in the way that people
handle stress
but equally that's a balance because
some people will handle it in different
ways this warrior warrior kind of idea
which which maybe have strengths and
weaknesses at different points so all of
it all of it becomes quite difficult to
see a way to evolve our way out of
trouble but certainly evolution has
provided some of the background that
sort of got us into trouble in the first
place yeah it's so weird the way that
our evolutionary heritage rears its head
when these new things happen right so
you bring in a new technology and you
know I wonder how the human makeup is
going to respond to this surplus of food
I wonder how this human makeup is going
to respond to this that hyper normal
stimuli coming from your mobile phone
and dopamine hits throughout the day and
all this sort of things and it's a it's
it's crazy man it's so it's so
fascinating this is why I've been loving
reading your book and some of Robert
Wright's work and Rob Henderson we
recently had him on talking about
evolution and dating and it's really
really cool so you mentioned there about
group size actually I want to ask how
does Dunbar's number relate to social
media yeah well this is a really
interesting one because it's the odd
thing I found when researching this idea
it was that you can find quite a lot of
people say all Dunbar's I was very
controversial and you'll kind of read
around and people will come up with
different numbers so the idea of the
Dunbar number is it's the number of
people that are in your social group
that you can feel comfortable with and
Robin Dunbar I think to find it it's
this idea of who you could go up to in a
bar and join for a drink without feeling
embarrassed about it and and the idea is
that that number maxes out at around 150
but there are layers within that so
there tends to be smaller numbers sort
of around five or so that it you know
you're very intimate close friends and
then a slightly wider sir
and expands out and the idea is that
when you go beyond the Dunbar number
that you you struggle with those social
groups and that social groups tend to
form naturally in human both in human
history actually if we look back and in
modern sort of human relationships into
these kind of groups of that number and
and and I saw let's figure out well
that's not true and you'll find this
other number and they say well no it's
350 and there's someone else that came
up with research he says well that's
1200 and and you've got all these sort
of people arguing the details but what I
noticed never really came out was the
idea that there was a limit and in fact
the upper limit seems to be down to our
ability to remember faces we at some
point I had yeah we can't cope with
anymore and so when you follow all this
through this idea of the Dunbar number
however which way you dice it you end up
with people deciding that yeah well
there is a limit actually we're just not
totally sure you know maybe the numbers
this maybe the numbers that but there is
a limit and that limit seems to always
be in the order of hundreds or you know
perhaps up to a thousand well when you
look at people's online social networks
they are much larger in many cases and
in many cases those online social
networks can be quite active as well so
it's not just a case of you've got say
ten thousand Twitter followers but you
only interact with two or three of them
actually you may have interactions with
a large number of them in different
shifting patterns so you can end up
actually with very large networks and
then when you intercept that I mean this
is the other thing right that's our
virtual world in one platform but of
course people have lots of different
platforms with different interactions on
and on top of all of that and this is
something that I wasn't able to really
find that much research on we have our
real world networks as well so we might
be maxing out or getting close to the
Dunbar number or whatever number we
decide in the real world and then we
lump on a whole load of different social
media platforms with all of these things
as well and and it seems that's that
people particularly people who are quite
ruminative and perhaps prone to
overthinking things maybe have a real
issue when when the social network of
the online world you know mixes with
their with their real world and it can
cause real problems but equally for some
people it can be a real big benefit
there is this slightly odd idea that you
know we know friendships are good and
healthy and we know that friends
there were some strong friendships are
good for mental health but having very
very large networks online for some
people can be very bad and yeah we might
my advice for that I I didn't write a
self-help book but if I was to write my
advice for these online social networks
is is learn how to mute and ignore and
block and learn how to manage them to
get what you want out them and I think
that's that's something I've learned but
I think it's also something that we
don't tend to think of when we join a
social network online and we expand
beyond our Dunbar number range if you
like we often don't think well why am I
doing this right what is the point you
know I see people on Twitter and
Facebook go I'm taking a break from this
now it's all too much and you think well
what were you doing you know what was
your reason for joining that network and
what are you trying to get out of it
we're not used to doing that because we
don't think of friendship groups in that
way in the real world right we don't we
don't always look at someone and go
right what am I going to get out of you
you know what's right what's my what's
my angle here in becoming you know named
friend of yours right that's not really
what we do not that costly you know like
yeah and also there's not a if you start
if you just stop speaking to someone
that happy you don't you don't remove
yourself entirely from the social
environment you don't go right that's it
I just fancy a little bit of time in
Monk mode for the next four months all
of you my entire social circle all of
you are our souls yeah I can't take you
anymore yeah that that doesn't happen it
is interesting I mean there's a bunch of
doorways open in my mind one of them
being play stupid games win stupid
prizes which is a quote from Navarre
Rubicon where he asks what is the prize
for winning the game that you are
playing at at the moment and one of
those for a lot of people will be
checking their phone every 30 minutes
like what is the prize for winning that
and this is something I I am the epitome
of someone who spent too much time on
their on their phones I'm a club
promoter by trade
I've sent and received millions of
messages on whatsapp millions so I am
very very accustomed to what it feels
like to have a tech addiction and I've
had to set myself such hard and fast
rules in a desperate attempt to try and
wrangle
technology which is far far far out
gunning me this race to the bottom of
the brainstem is I am just a pawn and
there is billions of dollars and the
smartest designers on the planet behind
every button press you know anyone
that's spent a bit of time looking at
Tristan Harris's stuff from the Sun of
humane researching he's we've spoken a
lot on the show about tech addiction
were big fan big advocate of phone
reduction on this show but yeah having a
separate device for social medias being
a big help for me not allowing my phone
into certain rooms of the house or if I
want to use my phone I've got to go into
the kitchen not sleeping with my son my
phone beside my bed has been a huge
difference having a hard digital sunset
on a night and it's like even this like
think about what I'm saying I'm having a
construct this bizarre world within the
world with weird little fences and rules
and stuff in a desperate attempt to stop
using a device that I had to pay a
ground and a half for yeah and this this
none of that would have made sense to
anyone ten years ago you know none of
what you've said and yet every single
thing that you've just said I thought
yep now that's actually a good idea hmm
yet not a bad plan yet you're right and
the devices that we hold in our hands
now they're they're like people that
design fruit machines know this and one
of the problems of gambling addiction
allure troubled problem gambling is it's
sort of more broadly known is that
particularly with slot machine gambling
it's the unexpected win associated with
bright lights and noises that form this
sort of perfect storm to reward those
pathways in our brain that make us
associate this with a good thing right
this is excellent we must carry on RIA
and that of course is at the root of
addiction of addictive behaviour it when
we think of drugs and things will more
broadly and and having a device that is
attractive to hold it's a pleasing it's
an aesthetically pleasing thing that
makes us feel good it rewards our reward
pathways because we're getting messages
and we're getting likes right we're
getting confirmation of what we what we
want affirmation of what we are
reinforces there and all of those things
that we're talking about there
psychological structures in our brain
that have evolved to keep us alive and
to breathe it's essentially you know the
reward pathway is basically there to eat
and have sex you know that's that's
effectively what is there to reward and
and now we do I talk about the hijack
hypothesis
in the booking when it when it comes to
two substances and drugs but of course
we can see the same sort of thing with
with devices and and you're right we're
having to come up with this whole sphere
in this whole realm of engagement and
management options but in order to
manage this technology that our huge
brains have let us devise and innovate
which is incredible when you think about
it but of course in there we also have
these involved mechanisms that are
perfect for um for making us addicted to
it and it's it is it's something that we
we need to win and look at my kids you
know they love technology and you know
ya have to you have to come up with
rules and I see lots of parents with
rules for their kids
alright no screens bla bla they don't
have those rules for themselves you know
I'm just as bad as anyone here you know
there's anyone this thing III need III
had to put the the kind of Twitter
launch icon I I've hidden it on sort of
screens about five kind of sweeps away
from my home screen and stuff I don't
keep it laid it up so I actually have to
go onto it and make a physical move
because if it's in the background
tweaking away at those vacations I know
that I know I won't be able to help
myself
we did a gotta gotta add that effortful
friction in man dopamine is a hell of a
drug and variable schedule rewards or a
hell of a delivery system yes you know
we are we were outgunned in that
department
so M can you tell us about the hygiene
problem I love this yes so I mean I
guess what one of the one of the issues
of the modern world and we can certainly
see it in lots of aspects of the
modeling is influence is inflammatory
diseases and actually inflammation in
general is now implicated and whole load
of different things and this is when our
immune system sort of over reacts to
what's going on it's actually one of the
sort of cytokine storms that people are
talking about causing deaths in Kobe
nineteen is it is in fact it's an immune
over response right and we can see it in
much less dramatic things but
nonetheless very life-changing and life
reducing kind of things like asthma for
example allergies you know not just sort
of peanut allergies and sort of
potentially serious or fatal allergies
but but but sort of lesser allergies as
well and we can find all of these things
in and one of the very SID
if you've ideas about this is the it was
became known as the hygiene hypothesis
which is effectively saying we are all
living such clean lifestyles now and we
use so many domestic cleaning products
and everything that that our immune
systems never get chance to learn friend
from foe right we never get the chance
to build up the idea in our bodies that
well these bacteria are good these
bacteria are bad and we end up with this
immune system that if you like hasn't
been to school properly and it's kind of
not learnt to respond properly and and
that's a really interesting idea because
it's very seductive if you see it
absolutely everywhere it's repeating in
the popular media particularly you know
jump on the hygiene hypothesis but when
you actually look back through the
history of it as a scientific idea and
the publishing of it it was never about
home hiding in that sense it was
actually the original idea was looking
at looking at the incidence of things
like asthma for example it looked at
household effects and the biggest
household if it was actually the size of
the family that you're in because he
gave you more they give you well it
gives you more interaction so if you
have more children basically those
children have more interactions with
children more very close interactions
more opportunities basically to ingest
bacteria and so on because you're dirty
and they're dirty and you've got gather
everybody do yeah and of course if you
look at our modern lifestyle we tend
have much less exposure to to outside we
live more inside lives than we certainly
than we evolved to live and so taken
together those ideas that actually have
some merit and they went on to form
what's become known as the old friends
hypothesis which is the idea that we koa
volved really with the whole suite of of
harmless organisms microorganisms
bacteria nematode worms and all sorts of
other things and that by being exposed
that he's very young in life you know
our adaptive immune system is able to go
okay call your friend your friend earth
you know [ __ ] we better sort you out you
know you're different right so yeah
that's the idea of the sort of the the
old friends hypothesis the hygiene
hypothesis of course then you have
developed greatly because of this idea
that we all clean our houses more than
we do let's see I mean looking back at
certainly at my grandmother's I'm
looking around my house right now I can
honestly say that there's absolutely no
way that my house is cleaner than theirs
you know and in fact people did lots of
studies of this and they looked at the
use of cleaning products and all this
sort of stuff and it really transpires
that it's not it's not this fact that
we're all so damn clean these days and
you know back in the day we all ate mud
and you know the size of house bricks
it's not it's not this sort of kind of
great great change it's actually dad's
the way we live and the modern you know
if you like the modern western lifestyle
the idea that we are inside much more as
children we tend to have less
interaction with other children you know
we're a crashing species almost you know
lots of children in in sort of ancestral
society certainly children would have
played together much more than they do
now you would have had family groups
mixing together much more than they
often do family size would have tended
to be larger there would have been
potentially more contact with with
animals and livestock than we have now
and so all of these changes to our
lifestyle can have an influence on on
the way our immune systems learn and we
can see similar sorts of effects in in
lots of different places around the
world I mean there was a really nice
natural experiment where a group of an
ethnic group in in northern Finland I
say a nice night to experiment nice in
inverted commas from a scientific
perspective an ethnic group got / border
effectively between Finland and Russia
and very very rapidly the the the
Russian group were living a sort of more
traditional lifestyle for them and a
more rustic lifestyle I guess you would
call it with association with animals
and so on and the group in Finland lived
were living a what we would describe as
a modern Western lifestyle it and and
very very quickly they were able to see
the differences in those to effectively
genetically identical populations they
hadn't had time to diverge but they were
the only difference between them now was
the environment they were in and they
were able to follow through the sort of
the fact that the the group that was in
this modern Western sort of setting had
more lifestyle relating the kind of
allergies and so on so it's a it's a
really interesting idea it is a tricky
one and it's it's the sort of thing
that's very difficult to do the type of
controlled experiments you know sort of
the the the gold standard kind of
medical trial that you would like to do
because of the ethical implications of
it but but certainly the chorus of
evidence is strongly points towards this
lifestyle effect
changing and resulting in these
allergies the question that we need to
know do I clean my house Oh No well
absolutely yeah and yes you should
because this is the other thing that
develops of course I mean I've heard
people say well you know I'm gonna take
little Toby out whatever and force-feed
him you know mud so if you push a
toddler into the ground it's good for
their health it's good for their this
was the idea and be well I won't clean
my house
well of course actually you know we
should hygiene and as we're seeing right
now hand hygiene basically is an
incredibly important thing the fact is
that we yeah being clean is good right
we need longer suffer from many of the
infectious diseases that we would we can
clean wounds we all of these things are
wonderful if and if you handle things
like chicken for example you know with
camp I live back to being quite rife in
some of these things yeah
God's sake wash your hands right what
should Jordan sound standing there all
these things are good but I had
Salmonella 18 months ago oh right and
wouldn't advise it no and actually in
something I mean I wrote a book about
five years ago which looked at us at a
complex relationship with bacteria and
one of the great surprises with that was
to and I don't remember the figures
offhand but was to see how many people
in this country died from food poisoning
from salmonella listeria sis and so on
it was quite shocking in fact there was
a there was a food poisoning outbreak if
I remember rightly up around the
northeastern you know five or ten years
ago I mentioned in that book you know
these things happen and that you're
right there they are not fun right so
definitely definitely have some basic
hygiene awful awful way to spend half
the month of October and most of the
month of November it doesn't stop man it
was it was savage anyway I want I won't
go into too much graphic detail and so
you looked at stress - what did you find
out there yeah I think what stress is
brilliant stress is actually what
started the book so I was I was looking
for it for another book to write and and
one of the things that came out from the
book on bacteria which was talking about
sort of allergies and so on I got
looking at inflammation and then started
reading around and ended up finding that
the stress in the modern world is this
big long Tina chronic stress is this
long term killer and that we don't you
know he's
understand that much about it so I
started thinking about stress as a topic
and then realized that it could expand
more so you know to base the basic story
behind stress is that stress is an
absolute lifesaver
stress is fundamentally this
fight-or-flight response right something
terrible happens we need to fix it right
now we can't wait for a sort of
homeostasis to take care of it it's not
right now we need to do something we
need to jack ourselves up and get ready
for it and so we get this fabulous
hormonal sort of ballet through our body
that releases all these hormones that
that elevate our heartbeat you know all
of that feeling that we're all familiar
with elevate the heartbeat elevate blood
pressure divert blood away from where
it's needed to it or where it's not
needed to where it's needed all of these
responses that we associate with that
and and that's a lifesaver it's and it
certainly saved I'm guessing that nobody
hasn't been saved at some point from
serious injury and potentially actually
death as a consequence of that response
and I walk you know real traffic
accidentally and something on your hand
that's hot you know all of those things
right that is that is a lifesaver and
every one of our ancestors would have
enjoyed that you know this sort of
stressed thankful chain all the way back
and in fact the biochemistry underlying
this this is a human thing you can get
back through the primates through the
mammals reptiles even some invertebrates
have had this system in place so this is
a really deeply a volte thing and it
saves our lives the problem is that if
you release all of these hormones all
the time they they have a harmful effect
it's got an allostatic load they have
they have this harmful effect on our
body system right it's a great thing
because you need it right now but you
can't be living with this all the time
and what we find in the modern world for
some people and potentially actually I
think first I think for many of us you
know some people deal with it better
than others but many of us are subject
to an almost constant drip-feed of
stress instead of having these majors
just for the vents that save your life
because it bears just jumped out from
behind a bush you know we have a
groaning email INBOX three phone calls
to take care of we mentioned it earlier
there's social media alerts and
notifications and you know 35 different
whatsapp threads half of which you're
unsure why you're even on anymore all of
these things go on there missed buses
and then of course we got financial
we're able to read the news and and take
on the woes of everyone else
some earthquake 2,000 miles when in
place you'd never heard obvious suddenly
becomes something to do with you you
know and and and all of these things
build up and the really sort of bad
thing about is we get this sort of drip
drip of stress but then that has
immediate effects it can cause headaches
and pain which of course can cause you
more worry and concern
it can cause sleeplessness which is a
major source of additional stress
because because then Southern you're an
insomniac and we end up with this saw as
maelstrom of very what we would think of
I think is a very modern day whoa a very
modern-day problem and it's coming at us
from all sides and and of course we
haven't lived this life for long enough
for us to really have a very solid
handle on what it might and how that
might affect us 70 and 80 year olds
right now did not grow up in the same
world that teenagers are growing up in
with the same stresses they had their
own stresses and different things as
well some of which would have been
greater individually but did they have
such a large stress landscape as we live
now that that that is something which we
are discovering all the time but but
what we do know is that more and more
evidence is gathering up that this
constant chronic stress micro stress
that we're under it is having an effect
on our on their health and well-being
and it's something that evolution isn't
gonna help us with evolution has given
us this wonderful tool and it allowed
some people to deal with it in different
ways and it's allowed some people to -
to have a variation in how they do it
but it's given us this wonderful
mechanism for keeping us alive but but
it's up to us I think to to regulate our
lives in the modern environment and
perhaps change our environment so that
we change that stress landscape because
yeah we can't live like this and what's
interesting is if you look at you know
you look at well actually NHS advice and
things it sounds more kind of
glastonbury than Harley Street in half
the time now most of the advice I have
to say is it's quite unhelpful it's
things effectively it's sort of says
pull yourself together calm down and you
know go and go for a walk or something
and actually that you know that might be
very good advice but it's not
necessarily device that someone that's
deeply stressed needs to hear so we
still need to work out the best language
for that but what's interesting is you
look at kind of
retreats for example or spars and it
almost feels like the more they strip
out of the modern world the more you pay
the more Spartan your existence is but
the board's gonna the more the more it's
gonna cost you right and yeah and I
stayed in a hotel in Africa actually a
while to get that dis spine had a big
sign you know leave your mobile phone
here that'll lock a fort and everything
it was very much stripping away aspects
of our modern life which we were
considered to be luxurious and they are
and safe and they are right we'd have a
very safe luxurious life really but
stripping those aspects away and giving
us some refuge from them is how we're
now trying to de-stress our lives and
that's I guess over the last couple of
months
you know we've sort of locked down one
of the the narratives that I've seen
coming out and this is probably down to
the sort of echo chamber that I mean in
social media but but I've seen people
very much say how important the natural
world has been to them how important it
is for them to now go out for a walk
every day for them to go and sit in
their garden and just watch the bees or
you know get their binoculars out and
and have a bird list and - and they're
saying that that is how they're dealing
with it in an effect whether they're
distressing by removing the modern world
slowing down taking it easy and I think
that is something that we definitely
need to do because the lives that we're
living now are luxurious safe privileged
and yet cause there's all kinds of
stressful woes and it feels like
something that we I think we can get on
top of that you know I think we just
need to identify what those stresses are
understand that we've got this
evolutionary background that isn't
helping us and work out how to get those
things to operate together and I think
that's something that possibly actually
the last few months might have helped
some people to come to terms with I know
it's helped me actually because the
whole work-life balance is put into
stark relief when you're you know
working at home constantly and you've
got kids around you you have to manage
those things and and you know now I find
myself going I mentioned earlier I find
myself going outside a lot more you know
I'm a I'm a biologist by profession I'm
a I'm a keen naturalist timer and I
I mean that's a historian by sort of
persuasion but I don't get that most
chance to do that
this year's the first year that I've
seen skylarks flying for years that I've
been out hearing cookies because
normally you know I would be at work and
then at home and then sorting it
probably on social media round and yeah
yes so being poor to balance those
things has actually helped me immensely
but of course first for some people it's
also been you know another stress well I
I understand and I appreciate the people
that have had stresses and stuff during
lockdown but the reduction of
stimulation the reduction of novelty the
reduction of opportunity for experience
as far as I'm concerned has resented
many people including myself attention
onto simpler pleasures so I was
mentioned this on a podcast day of the
week that over the last two and a half
months three months or whatever it's
been since I've been in lockdown I have
been able to do my morning walk and
watch the trees go from bare branches to
getting ready to leave two buds two
flowers and I know this I know which
trees went first I have like the shape
of them like some of them have given
like weird pet names to and obviously
this is just all part of the odd
psychosis that's going on inside of my
mind but like and I took notice of my
flower the clematis I've got in my
garden I never I'm living this house for
five years but I've never taken notice
of stuff like that so I do agree that
hopefully we've been able to reset dial
back that hyper normal stimuli dial
Bangla the constant it's Jo Ann's
barbecue this weekend and we've got to
hurry off because we got to go to our
parents down in Surrey on Saturday and
blah blah blah I really do hope that
that is something that people take away
the fact that they can have more simple
more easy and enjoyable experiences and
hopefully kind of reconnect themselves
with that grander vastness that nature
does it makes you feel small right it
reminds you that your problems aren't
that big so the two key takeaways we've
got so far that I've I've got from this
but three key takeaways number one sleep
with your phone outside of your bedroom
number two if you've got a child you
worry about getting ill shove-its facing
some mud number three if you want to
really enjoy your life then loincloth
mud hut out in the middle of somewhere
completely barren and stark and just
live out there for like a week and
you'll come back and you're just gonna
be fully actualized and full of Zen so
those those are the three takeaways I've
got so far up next are we evolved to be
violent yes now this was this was a
chapter which I've found particularly
interesting to come up from from a
zoological perspective because I think
you can find lots of people that will
suggest that humans are the only people
they are the only species that will that
kills its own kind and as a biologist I
I know that that's - I mean that's total
right yeah it's absolutely incorrect
I've studied leaf cutting ants and
honeybees for example in some depth and
both of those highly social species
right that we look at in terms of
harmony I mean but these are virtually
honey bees eventually synonymous with
harmonious living well actually you know
the Queen when she emerges will kill her
sister Queens though they will eat each
other's eggs yeah I used to study these
ants called dine upon record recep's
huge things they're asleep biggest dance
in the world they live in Brazil they've
been relatively small colonies about 10
or 15% of the ants in a colony are
involved in all these antagonistic
interactions between each other they're
sisters but it doesn't make any
difference to them because they might
get the chance to sort of become the
breeder in the colony and then that
they're trying to kill each other and in
fact what what someone did fairly
recently was to do what's got a
phylogenetic analysis so they looked
across the broad sweep of mammals and
they looked at their relationships
between the different groups the
evolutionary relationships between the
different groups and the incidence of
inter individual death but basically
members of the same species conspecifics
killing each other
fatal conflicts if you like and what
they found was that 40% of mammal
species had solid evidence of that
happening 40% of them and their
suggestion was that actually they would
have found it in more except him you
know we haven't studied most of these
things basically the rule seems to be
that if they've been study for any
length of time it turns out that they
probably are killing each other at one
point or another do [ __ ] out each other
at one
and here's the brilliant thing you look
at they're they they they illustrate it
this beautiful circle of all the species
going around so you can sort of see them
all in one place
and there's a really massive kind of
lump of violent interactions and you
look at it it's the primates the group
that we come from are unusually violent
for mammals even though you can find
this violence throughout and then you
sort of look further in and you know the
Apes violence still and and so we have
come from a a violent lineage Oh perfect
heritage yeah there we we do have that
heritage for it and you can come up with
all sorts of quite plausible
evolutionary scenarios as to why
violence can be at times a great problem
solver
you know if particularly for example if
you're a group living animal and you
come into conflict with other groups for
example which would have been at some
point an issue but also to resolve
conflicts within groups so you have
violence can definitely be an advantage
at times and it can be a lifesaver
particularly in sort of in sort of
conflict times so yeah I think we can
over do our sort of violence history but
over the course of our of our evolution
there are times when violence would have
been a definite advantage and then if
you you look at us as a physical unit
where we're pretty handy right we're
we're a decent size we're quite strong
we've we've got long limbs which provide
perfect kind of levers and perfect sort
of gives you very good reach you can
swing a fist very very fast we've got
feet knees elbows we've got heads and
skulls but it'd be the front of my skull
is quite tough where yeah we've got some
pretty pretty decent sort of bits about
us physically that allow us to inflict
harm on to others so inbuilt weapons
here and there yeah exactly I mean sure
you know we don't have teeth and claws
that are particularly effective but
nonetheless we're not we're not badly
put together there was I came across
this fabulous some sort of argument by
biologists who who sort of tried to put
for the argument that the fists and the
way that the fist is made and and but
wrists and sort of the the architecture
of the human hand and everything was was
to do with with a fist that we were sort
of pre adapted you know the fists were
not pre adapted the fist was actually an
adaptation for fighting and he'd also
put forward the idea that the the human
male face and differences in bone
structure between males and females it
was basically a sort of punch proof
face that was his kind of way that the
impact comes in and Athiya that we'll be
able to withstand exactly that say so
that those ideas it must be said were
met with some fairly robust criticism in
in a literature but nonetheless actually
some people also said well you're able
to something in it so there's there's
sort of an idea that we might have there
might be adaptations I'm not really sure
I buy into that but certainly as a
physical specimen we yeah we and we have
some fairly useful attributes for
violence of course we then also got a
pretty decent brain that's both
innovative so we're pretty good at using
weapons and tools and and can plan ahead
so we can really start to start to bring
all these things together so it doesn't
seem necessarily surprising that we are
are violent I guess one of the surprises
is that we're not more violent and of
course then we see evolution coming in
as well and there's lots of evidence and
ideas about sort of how we have evolved
mental mechanisms and neural mechanisms
for for reining ourselves back emotions
for example things like shame and some
of the emotional sort of side of things
are hypothesized by some to be to be
ways to reduce our violent tendency so
it was quite an interesting in and out
for me this sort of thing be and what's
really interesting as well is that you
can find perfectly good well put forward
theses by people that say we are more
violent now than we were very very learn
and theses that say no we're actually
much less violent we were learn the
theses that say no when no more violent
that we were before it's it's almost as
though we we have not really got a firm
grip on it but what I did find was that
there is evidence for genetic components
to violence and when people have looked
at at violence and tried to it's always
very tricky of course to separate nature
from nurture and human studies but but
it does seem that that violence in the
broader sense of the term and what we
might you know subsumed within that
there there may be some genetic
component to it as well and what that
suggests is that it cause has been under
the influence of evolution so evolution
has certainly had a role to play of
course in the modern world and in one
way of thinking you know we have a very
different view on that and just because
evolution you know just because we've
come from an unusually violent sort of
phylogenetic origin
and just because we have all this
ability to be able to do this and just
because at some point in the past there
may have been selection for it you know
that is not an excuse for violence
because equally we've had selection and
mechanisms that prevent us from acting
through on that because what our secret
is you know our secret I guess our
ultimate goal is to work out why it is
and and what triggers there are in some
people that make some people much more
violent better than others and and
that's that's really I hope I think of
lots of people looking at the
evolutionary history of this sort of
things to try and get some sort of
handle on on how we might if you like
cure or treat violence but there's a
there's an argument there there'll be a
number of people that would hear you say
or hear researchers say that we're
looking at ways to cure violence and
they would think they're trying to
neuter the population they're trying to
make us helpless and weak and unand
appendant and they're what they want
this sort of utopia and again what we're
talking about the misalignment between
human makeup and current environment the
fact that the fact that we have this
flinch response now where the vast vast
vast majority of things don't require a
flick we don't need to be scared of a
cold shower and yet every morning when I
go and have a cold shower I shot myself
just before I go in know what it's gonna
be like and I know that I'm fine or for
instance when I'm doing breath work
let's say that I'm doing some quite
challenging holotropic breathwork and uh
I'm scared that I'm choking and I can
feel the gasp response coming it's like
I know I'm not choking I'm in complete
control it's me that's holding my breath
and yet we have all of these misaligned
concerns and warning signs that go off
around us and there's gonna have to be a
line where we begin to align the way
that we are the way that we operate to
the environment more effectively but
there must be an Overton Window to that
where you actually push it so far that
you essentially no longer become human
yes and and I think yeah we need to be
we need to be careful when we develop
these sorts of
he's too far because actually of course
things are always a bit more complete
we're not gonna find a gene for exactly
there's not a gene for violence right
there's not going to be a simplistic way
of curing it but I think we can get some
insights into what our clear problems in
the world today and and violence can be
in in the broad is is clearly a problem
domestic violence is a huge issue and a
huge problem violence towards children
is clearly a problem violence towards to
alter everyone unjustified violence that
let's put that inverted commas and sort
of and sort of park it but just just
let's assume that in some cases violent
responses are justified or desirable to
defend yourself for example most most of
the violence in the world is is not
defensive it is not in that sense and we
see the escalation of violence across
the world
you know resulting in the--in manifest
atrocities up to the level of genocide
clearly there is a problem and even
understanding it's gonna help us in some
way a much more personal level because
people when we get to these big
abstractions and we start to actually
talk about there were you genocides and
everyone can go I'm not a part of a
genocide it's like okay everyone's been
on a night out I've stood on the front
door of over a thousand nightclubs right
and I have seen hundreds and hundreds of
fights yeah so many guys that are
posturing that are looking to not lose
face in a group of drunk people who
don't even know who they are and won't
remember what happened the next day and
you think this is I'm watching it
thinking this is an evolutionary
adaptation to not wanting to drop down
the pecking order within your tribe gone
so haywire that it is unbelievable
it's a pure evolutionary if we were if
we were sort of alien biologists
dropping onto earth and we saw that
classic drunken nightclub brawl oh come
on yeah well first of all this posturing
right so so you get displayed so in
case it's often vocal display so people
will start adopting a way of speaking
which they wouldn't normally adopt
they're shouting there they're swearing
at each other in there they're
name-calling right that is no different
from red deer bellowing at each other
right it's trying to work out who's the
biggest and people might back down at
that point and if they don't they start
displaying a nice eating deer right
they'll start walking parallel to each
other they're sizing each other up
basically to work out if it's worth you
see that in men right they'll start
putting their arms out come on in come
on then they're trying to make
themselves look bigger it is pure pure
animal behavior at that point and that
is that is has an evolutionary origin
its display first of all the threat
displays then we get physical displays
and then if it escalates of course it
goes into into a fight and you're right
it's to do with status it's to do with
access to females it's to do with access
to resources of course in the modern
world those things are slightly
subverted and become somewhat bent and
twisted but the basic essence of it is
the same and then of course people will
start fighting and what they're
generally doing I mean if you watch if
you watch people having it you know as
you've done much more than I have I'm
sure the sort of fighting they're doing
is either a very weird imitation of the
type of fighting that they see on
television and films which we are
immersed in constantly which of course
doesn't doesn't really work because it's
there to look good or it is it is brutal
all the fancy kicks in the world aren't
gonna be as good as stomping on
someone's head and that's what you
actually see in the real world and that
that is where that you know that is
where people get killed in these
ridiculous threat displays we have a
problem when that's happening like for
the most part what I see and that's a
really interesting insight I've never
thought of before for the most part I
see fights which are grander and less
effective than they need to be I've
never in all the fights I've watched
seen someone bite another person and
yeah if you were trying to pull a
murderer off your child yeah you would
be do it would be a be in the eyes you'd
be in the throat but it or not that sort
of fighting is this almost like burrow
slightly ritualized style yeah this kind
of weird dramatized like kayfabe WWE
[ __ ]
so look I've got a couple more questions
but I want to do a quick fire round for
you now
quick fire round quick fire round is
going to be try and give us a brief
evolutionary explanation for different
emotions I'll try see what you can do
okay so first up pride pride well that's
an interesting one isn't it pride I
suppose I mean this is purely the worst
type of armchair adoptionism but I guess
pride is almost a sort of self rewarding
thing isn't it
it's sort of an affirmative kind of self
rewarding I wouldn't be at all surprised
if feelings of pride a few to MRI
someone that's done something that's
prideful that it doesn't affect that
reward pathway in some way because if
you've done something that makes you
feel proud you may be you might want to
end up doing it again or or seek that
emotional out again I wonder if that's
next next one Envy well I suppose Envy
basically comes down to resource
resource management and territory and so
on isn't it you're envious of things
which will give you more status and more
reproductive power ultimately I can
imagine I've got two black birds that
live and the males are constantly
ferreting each other one one is on the
street opposite and one's on my roof and
they both got pretty decent territory
but you can see each of them eyeing up
the other one I'm guessing they're Envy
in humans is probably a more
sophisticated and more intellectualized
version of that we see something we want
that will give us some status some
resource that we need and an MV eats
away people it motivates so it's
probably linked in some way to those
motivational pathways that gets us to
you know get something that we perceive
to be a value to us that's my uh
adaption isn't like it - more so
loneliness well loneliness is um is is
an interesting one isn't it that's
something that ironically perhaps in the
modern world of interconnectiveness we
find ourselves less connected and we see
loneliness
I'm loneliness is an extremely
unpleasant thing to experience whether
that's a pathological reaction to the
situation so if you like outside of the
realm of it's not an evolved response
it's simply a a symptom a disease
response or whether there is some
evolved response to it because it's such
an unpleasant way of feel
stimulates us I I don't know but I guess
one of the things that we see with
people that are chronically lonely is it
doesn't necessarily drive people towards
seeking out humans in fact if anything
it tends to lead to further isolation
and further loaning so I wonder whether
a lone loneliness might actually be be a
sort of a symptom almost a disease if
you like a symptom of something rather
than a uninvolved emotional bond but
yeah I'm guessing there'll be there'll
be people listening to this that I know
a lot more about the evolution of
emotion than they're going in common
please in the comments below and correct
us throughout this or sir I've yeah
absolutely five times about shoving a
child's face in the mud it's fine final
one right I've asked this question to a
number of different people and this is
that this is the most difficult one
have you seen interstellar the film I
haven't yet no okay
so in interstellar there's this short
period short sequence where the they're
talking about the evolution of human
emotions and they're trying to justify a
work out why we still love people that
have died so grief yeah I suppose well
it's different from grief isn't it grief
is almost that separation sort of thing
the pursuer like a continuation of love
of people that have died and how all
that fitness enhancing you know I guess
I guess in a sense who maybe we want we
want that to be us some sense perhaps
that's one of those things that's gone
beyond simple fitness enhancement and
it's a product of this is this is such a
squirrely and and a weasel irresponsible
perhaps that's one of the products of
the complexity of our brain that simply
emerged from the the background of all
those neurological connections maybe
maybe that's just a a spandrel if you
like an evolutionary kind of loads of
other things have evolved for different
reasons and as a consequence of them we
get these interconnections that lead to
something that we've got explained that
that is that it's a idea I like it I
like the fact that you've got this kind
of like haywire
add on the kind of like a bug in the
system so you could think again this if
I thought about that question loads and
this is the first time you're eliciting
a lot of new thoughts here on which is
correct
what you could have is your brain is
unable to work out the fact that your
feelings for someone the love that you
had for someone that they're no longer
there then it's actually a denial of
death almost some web back back inside
of you I don't know why that would be
evenly fed back well and I guess I guess
a denial of death is probably a very
good thing right if if if you refuse to
believe that death is there and you well
no actually accepting that death is
there as much better isn't it because
you know how bad death would be for your
fitness so you ruthlessly tried to avoid
it so actually kind of a ignoring death
I'm not sure I'm gonna yeah when you
watch interstellar you'll know the exact
bit that I was talking about so um but
final question what's what what happens
next we've said at the very beginning of
this conversation that human evolution
is kind of a bit moot now or at least
for the time being for isn't as long as
the environment changes fast as hell
evolution is kind of just spinning its
wheels is what what does that mean as we
go forward I think I think what it means
is that we it's kind of like we need to
sort of grow up a little bit don't we
we've we've reached this point now in in
in our civilization and particularly
over the last few few decades in the
last generation or two we've we've
really reached a very critical point and
and perhaps even a tipping point the way
that we that we view the world and see
the world I think I think we need to
embrace the fact that we are incredible
creatures right we are amazing we can
control our environment to a ridiculous
degree we can explore space we can smash
atoms we can do all of those things and
too often I think we we sit back and say
oh but you know we're we're rubbish and
we bla bla bla and like aren't we awful
and we know we can't run as fast as a
cheetah or whatever no we're incredible
we're the fastest strongest most
intelligent creature on this planet we
embrace that and we should have used
that in a much more effective fashion I
think to do that we're going to have to
accept the fact that we are animals that
we have these kind of evolutionary
echoes that influence things both
consciously subconsciously and also
within our bodies and the way we respond
to things we always have to embrace all
of that and and much understand
ourselves in a much better way I think
if we're going to move forward because
you're right evolution is not going to
get us out of this we're going to get us
out of this but for us to do that we
have to really deeply take on what we
are and we are flesh-and-blood animals
that have been subject to evolution but
we're also something incredible because
we've got in our heads the most complex
structure that we know of in a universe
that's capable of innovation that that
we can't yet imagine an imagination that
we we can't quite fathom so I think we
just need to bring all these components
together but underpinning all that and
this was really the big surprise to me
is is the fact that we're not very good
at thinking about the future eeveelution
Assen equips us for that evolution
doesn't care what's going to happen in
three generations time it cares what
happens now right we have evolved in our
heuristics and our brain have evolved as
kind of here and now things and we
devalue us actually we think of
ourselves as different people in the
future future us is is sort of treated
as the same as everyone else but we can
stop that we can actually do experiments
that show that if you just tweak people
a little bit and prepare them and say
listen you're gonna need to make a
decision for future you but future yous
going to be you yeah it's gonna have the
same hopes and fears and emotions and
everything if you prime people in that
way they treat future them better than
they treat a future them without that
priming and I think we need to learn
those little lessons that that let us
take our evolutionary heritage into turn
on its head and make it into a strength
you know there's sort of Judo approach
of understanding our enemy against
itself and I think that's that's where
we're gonna need to go I think we're
gonna need to be much more understanding
about what we are both in the sort of
philosophical sense but also in the
biological and sort of very real
flesh-and-blood sense and understand
that heritage would also understand what
it means for us right now and and and
and perhaps perhaps then we we have a
who
we have some hope because yeah we are in
every axis really it's very hard to find
anyone arguing against a point that we
seem to be right now in history it quite
a important point in terms of human
population the way we're treating the
planet our environmental issues the
social issues you mentioned earlier
ideas of social inequality and
everything you know it very much feels
like we're at that yeah we're at that
important point and I think we're going
to need to understand our past and our
present in order to move on into that
future which of course we need to get a
better understanding off as well so it's
tricky tricky times but it's exciting
times as well you know there's there's
hope I think there is so much complexity
to hold in that you know and and I
genuinely do hope that the more abstract
more long-term rational side of us that
allows us to transcend the terrible
social norms and the awful evolutionary
heritage and all of the the fears and
the worries and and the crap that we've
managed to the baggage that has been
given to us by our ancestors in an
environment that were no longer fit to
be in and but it requires a lot of
social change like if if evolution isn't
going to do it then it has to be a
combination of wisdom acquisition by the
individual social cohesion by small and
local groups by bureaucratic and
political change by people in power who
actually understand every layer below
that and then a global movement toward
understanding that we are one species
one planet one shot at this you know we
didn't even start talking about
existential risk and stuff like that but
that's a whole new rabbit hole for us to
go down but you know the Fermi paradox
actually seems to stop yeah we need to I
think we've tended to think of
globalization a lot of the times this
way it means I can get cheap trainers
from Indonesia and fly to Australia
you're absolutely right we need to
realise that actually we are we are
globalized now we can see ourselves in
the
and literally if you know from space we
can see ourselves we need to embrace
that we need to embrace what we are as a
species much more I think and and
realize our problems and and you're
right it's gonna happen at all levels
but it needs to happen at all levels it
needs to be individual it needs to be
local it needs to be national but it
needs to be global as well and and we
can start to see movements moving in
that direction but one thing one thing
that we can be sure of right in human
endeavour we usually end up going
further than we thought we would but it
usually takes a bit more time you know
you look back to the 50s and people were
predicting we were living on the moon
and and and and whatever by the 1970s
but but in fact they didn't predict half
of the things that we've managed to do
they just got the timing wrong you know
so we really I think we it's gonna take
us a bit longer this is this is not
gonna be a ship that's gonna happen
overnight but hopefully we're gonna be
heading in the right direction I love it
I'm unfit for purpose when human
evolution collides with the modern world
will be linked in the show notes below
have you got any of the websites any
other stuff you want to plug no just
that one for now there is a radio 4
program coming out this it's not linked
to this actually but it's quite
interesting and sort of a Rose out some
of the ideas where we look at humans as
prey so we're looking at that how how we
are eaten around the world actually by
various animals and how serious that can
be in certain areas but also we look
back to our evolutionary history and
look at the influence of not man the
hunter which is the sort of glamorous
way that we used to think of it but man
the hunted and the importance of that
environment on a revolution so some
links there as well I called that
program is going to be called on the
menu and it's out at the end of June and
that's on BBC Radio 4 amazing that
sounds awesome I've never seen any
ancestral historical analysis of what
happened of how we would have acted as
prey the ways that we would have hidden
from animals who totally right we get
this sort of hyper romantic view of the
berry-picking while the wife's at home
and then the killing that saber-tooth
tiger and all this austere you don't get
the how did we cower in caves
narrative very much so that that sounds
absolutely fascinating on the menu
BBC Radio 4 I'm excited man but look
thank you so much unfit for purpose is
sick it's an awesome book everyone that
has been listening if you've enjoyed
this if you've got an interest in
evolutionary theory and and all of the
stuff that we've gone through today then
head to the show notes below and grab it
feel free I'll also link professor
Hart's Twitter below so feel free to ask
them on there and tell him what you
think he got wrong what you think all
right Adam thank you so much for you
time man
thank you it's been a pleasure
[Music]